when I saw the reports of the U.S
government
planning to investigate uaps I said to
myself what's a UAP and then you'd read
the fine print and it's unidentified
aerial phenomenon and I said to myself
that kind of sounds like UFO but
regardless whether we're talking about
UFOs or uaps both of them refer to
stuff happening in the sky
and you don't know what it is
period
okay we can agree on that because that's
what the U stands for unidentified if
there's something in the sky that you
later identify it goes from being a UFO
to an ifo an identified flying object
and then you move on why should the
government be interested in UFOs seems
to me if something over our head could
possibly pose a threat to us to our
safety to our health our economy who are
you gonna call call the military the Air
Force I'm not surprised that there's
military governmental level military
interest in trying to figure out what is
happening in the sky among objects you
can't otherwise identify no problem with
that allocate some portion of the
Pentagon budget to identifying them
people have come to equate UFOs with
aliens which is a curious equation in
our brains because they go something
like this there are lights in the sky
doing something I've never seen anything
do before I can't explain it I don't
know what it is therefore it's a
visiting alien from another planet so
what we tend to do is explain away our
ignorance with aliens now that's just
intellectually lazy aliens can't have
done all of that it happens on many
levels the people who see the pyramids
and rather than credit the African
culture who created them because you
don't know how somebody did it thousands
of years ago you can't figure it out and
you're not giving them the intellectual
credit for having accomplished it so you
say aliens help them it's a common sort
of fallback position what I would say is
as a scientist you learn to
embrace the unknown
you encounter something you don't know
what it is I want to find out more
and you don't assert that you know what
it is after you've just admitted you
don't know what it is
you don't know what it is let's perform
more experiments let's get better data
let's keep investigating it so
I don't have any problems
continuing to investigate stuff in the
sky
[Music]
you being a scientist I'm interested
what do you guys in your community
looking out into space for your entire
life how do you view UFOs
but first of all I love me some aliens
and nobody doesn't love the aliens okay
that would be a discovery of of all of
civilization
if aliens showed up and we sat down and
had tea with them actually if they
showed up and we did anything with them
right
so let me offer just a couple of
perspectives
just so we can let me orbit it first
with perspectives and then I'll land in
the middle by the end okay so first of
all notice how frequently aliens are
hostile
to us as portrayed in movies and that
goes back to the Twilight Zone and
before of course the one of the more
famous episodes they had aliens in many
episodes by the way but this is back in
the 1960s late 50s that uh an episode
called to serve man where aliens came
and they helped us grow crops and they
gave us secrets to our energy needs and
they there was peace all over the Earth
and they invited us to go back and visit
them
and uh
they accidentally left behind a book
called to serve man within their own
sort of hieroglyphic kind of text and so
they got all the best cryptographers
looking at it and after everyone has
already decided yeah let's go visit
their Planet because they're obviously
Superior to us and we're all very well
fed because the crops were Bounty all
over the Earth and then you know they
find out that to serve man it was a
cookbook that's awesome
it is rumored I've not studied this but
I've I've read studies that to a child
it is far worse to be eaten
than to just die
so of all the ways to die they're not
even afraid of other ways to die but the
idea of being eaten is particularly
horrifying I think to anybody that's
what well okay especially children but
and that's why the fairy tales are
always involved the witch eats you the
ogre eats you the truth they don't just
stab you right they don't shoot you they
don't throw you off a cliff they each
and this is terrifying and I think this
is why we as children
um deeply respect T-Rex ask any kid who
their favorite animal is T-Rex because
you respect anything that can eat you
right and then you bring them over to
astrophysics and say what's your
favorite object in astrophysics it's
black holes because they can eat you
okay okay cool all right so here's the
thing
so the this evil alien concept I
it feels like we are basing this
on actual evidence
of how we treat each other
rather than on any notion
of how
aliens would actually treat us
how many
photographs
are taken every day
everybody's got a smartphone right
almost everybody high resolution
and if you're not taking a photo you're
taking a video
and so if there's something unusual and
interesting you're taking a video of
that we have video of stuff you never
got videos of before so you'd think in
Alien Encounter would be rare but you've
got a smartphone and you can stream it
in the old days when people said did you
take pictures of the alien that abducted
you yeah but they stole the film or I
got the film home and the whole role was
blank because the aliens Zapped it or
whatever so so it's a recording device
but a streaming device is not a
recording device so you can live stream
whatever is happening all right so so
you would expect given how many reports
of abductions there were right of
decades past that somebody would have
that on you know that'd be posted by now
and it hasn't been so this leads me to
think strongly
that people's imaginations got the
better side of their life experience
when they came back to report on having
been abducted okay so there's that
so so that's aliens that's just aliens
but how about UFOs so you see something
flying it's something you don't know
what it is
and let me just say
I was going to Tweet this too maybe I
should I was going to say
the fact
that you don't know what it is
is not evidence
that you know what it is
[Laughter]
okay that's actually that's pretty
profound because that's exactly what
people do so there's lights in the sky
moving in a peculiar way and you can't
explain it it's unidentified and it's
flying and it's an object so it's a UFO
it must be alien and then
so I don't know what it is
therefore it must be ABCD Elemental P
alien and I'm thinking you just admit it
you don't know what it is what it is
that's kind of where that stops
we're done here okay it's time to get
more and better data okay so now in
science
do you know why science exists because
the human sensory system sucks the
advance of Science and civilization with
it came about
primarily because we invented machines
to replace our sensory system
because it fails so badly
and look why do we have whole books on
what do you call them optical illusions
right right those are fun nobody doesn't
love enough good optical illusion and
and what is an optical illusion it's oh
there's a line and it's it's simple
right it's simple line drawing on a
white page is that line bigger than the
other one I don't know are they the same
size oh my gosh look how easy it is to
fool you
and this is just a simple line drawing
now I'm going to have something
complicated in in Twilight with in a in
a sky with you've never seen But and and
now you I'm expecting you to give me an
accurate account of what just happened
no so in science
eyewitness testimony is the lowest form
of evidence there is
in fact it's so low we don't even
we basically don't accept it wow so when
you see people say this was a Navy pilot
who's extrained and he's a credible
witness for what he saw
uh you're saying species you're saying
that guy is just as much a dumb ass as
anybody standing on the ground
that Navy pilot or not being a human
being he's susceptible to the same
perception bias that anybody else
perception buys and it's not purposeful
you know right they're not trying to
it's just the consequence of
the human being trying to make sense of
their world
and when things don't make sense we have
the urge to
make it make sense so that we can think
about it in some way that's consistent
with our life experience
so I've had people say oh I saw this
this bright light in the sky it was huge
so no they meant it was just bright
because the vocabulary is I I saw this
light and it was a few inches above
Marty's Deli
what do you mean a few inches was it an
angle it was in the sky you know so our
even our capacity to retell things is
compromised because we're human all
right so all I'm asking for is among the
six billion images and videos uplifted
to the internet every day that are high
resolution
it'd be nice if a few of them had an
alien getting out of their spacecraft
or are you going up to greet theater
give me some footage of that some
high-res videos but you don't have that
what you have is lately fuzzy
Navy video
monochromatic
and so you're telling me that the aliens
are only revealing themselves to the
Navy
well that's not a bad place to start
they do have the best Uniforms
Plus if the aliens are everywhere but do
you know how many planes when we're in
full flying mode how many planes are
crisscrossing this planet every minute
all right if we were if there were
aliens all over the place this would be
like a major hazard
for airplanes okay and we'd be seeing
them all the time all right so we take
this one case out of tens or hundreds of
thousands and it's a weird thing and
nobody can explain it and all of a
sudden everybody can explain it so
that's the I don't know what it is so
therefore I know what it is so
by the way we as scientists we'd love to
meet the aliens I have no problems with
this we just need better evidence than
your credible witness I just need better
evidence than your fuzzy video
[Music]
Amanda Clark uh writes and says if the
government did have contact why were
they not share it with us I know it
starts from a conspiracy theory place
but I just wonder if there be any
logical reason to keep the info from us
good question yeah is the government
hiding
go ahead Ben tell me I mean if you can I
mean maybe maybe I'm not clear to hear
this are they listening I don't know
yeah
um look I mean this is this is
this is a perfect question and and you
know I've pointed this out to people
before you know I've asked people like
why exactly you know for the conspiracy
theorist why why is it that you think
that people would would be the
government would make all this and not
just one government of course we're
talking an international Consortium
spanning many administrations and
countries and decades uh to all suppress
this evidence and it just doesn't make
sense and people say well you know it's
because you know if if people really
thought that that aliens were contacting
us then you know then it would be
they'll be mass panic and of course the
the reply to that is but if you look at
polls many people already think that
aliens have contacted us so that that's
not happened so that that explanation
well they would be mass panic no no no
no a lot of you like as you said you
know depending on what not what's what
poll you look at of between you know a
quarter and a third of them already
think that so that clearly hasn't
happened they they don't have an answer
they're still going to work at them
every day you know yeah but can you make
the argument just because somebody might
think that it happened is very different
from being presented with hard evidence
yeah well there may be something to that
I mean uh Ben it's okay to say well I
believe that it's true but if if the the
Government powers that bee who can get
to the bottom of it presumably say uh
well yes we've actually been we have the
aliens freeze-dried and stacked up at
area 51. if they say that and everybody
would go non-linear but if they say no
we don't have any evidence of alien
visitation everybody would say that's a
they're they're lying to us so I don't
see how it solves anything but
supposedly if they did do it I mean do
you think that people would be riding in
the streets really we're not going to
work today we're going to ride on the
streets because they've got aliens no
this this is absurd I mean again they're
they're the government is in a no-win
situation because the thing is that that
even if the government came totally
clean tomorrow and Declassified
everything and said look here's what's
going on you know at Area 51 here's uh
you know Air Force bases the fact is
that the conspiracy theorists wouldn't
believe them they would assume there's
there's another layer of the cover-up so
and this is inherent and of course in
conspiracy theory thinking is that
there's no way to disprove it because
anything you offer them as counter
evidence is taken as part of the
conspiracy yeah you're part of the
cover-up band yeah there's there's no
way to argue with these people because
you know it's like well anything you say
so you know the and it's again that's
one of the problems is that you know
when from the government point of view
no matter what they say people aren't
going to believe it so you know let let
them wonder what's at Area 51 who cares
[Music]
how much of the Galaxy have we actually
searched for Life see because I every
time I'm out in the street someone says
we've looked and we haven't found any
are we alone that's right and I'm trying
to find a way
to tell them
we're not likely alone
but they know we've been looking for a
while so how do you how do you deal with
this so I try and tell people about all
the different ways you might have to
look to get it right all the different
frequencies be at the right time looking
at the right place all this has to come
together right now
that big volume that you need to search
through
cool to the volume of the Earth's oceans
okay all that water
so how much have we sampled in the last
50 years
[Music]
one 12 ounce glass
it's not a lot and so if you were
looking for fish in the ocean
are there any fish in the earth's ocean
here's a glass I'm going to scoop up a
glass
look at it and there aren't any fish in
there
can you claim that there are no fish in
the ocean yeah you'd be stupid to do
something yeah and so it's the fact that
the it's hard to comprehend how big the
search is so you can't understand how
little we've done however exponentials
will save us because our ability to
search means growth of Technology
Computing special growth of storage
retrieval of information all that stuff
it gets faster and better all the time
Seth what's your take on that it's
exploration it's exploration it's like
sitting around in the bars of Europe you
know 300 400 years ago and saying yeah
what do you think Ralph do you think
there's a continent at the bottom of the
globe right and you can say well what
good is it going to do to find it if
it's there what we will learn is that
we're unique yes but we're not special
I'm special
but if we are actually alone it would
seem to me that our responsibility is
even greater because if the universe has
no other Consciousness in it other than
ours it seems like we owe it to the
universe to keep ourselves going if if
there is no intelligent life other than
us then the universe itself
loses meaning in a way because there's
nothing to to observe it David Hamilton
mayaga is Puerto Rico would it be more
likely that any intelligent signal we
detect is simply an echo of life now
long gone how could we tell the
difference and if we couldn't can we
still claim we aren't alone Seth yeah
well look people ask that you pick up a
signal it took you know who knows how
many years to get here maybe they're
gone well maybe they are gone but you
know what the time it takes for a signal
to get here might be tens hundreds
thousands of years you know the U.S post
Office might give me a letter from my
aunt tomorrow and maybe my aunt has died
since she sent that letter it's possible
but the lifetime Advance is pretty long
compared to the functioning to The
Postal Service so the chances are she's
still around I think that if we pick up
a signal yeah maybe it's 100 year old
signal but I'd like to think that they
haven't self-destructed in the last
century good next James coultas
Bentonville Arkansas if seti discovered
extraterrestrial intelligence how long
would it take to share the discovery to
the public and what is the process
involved with making it public I would
say a billionth of a second
do you tell the president does the
president get to know first
no I look we don't have a call list you
know start with this William I mean we
have had false alarms in 1997 we had a
false alarm that for most of the day
looked like the real deal and I kept
waiting for the Pentagon to call the
White House to call the only people that
called were the New York Times and the
facts are that they were calling within
hours of us finding the signal
yes so this notion that the government
is somehow in control and no this is not
the case the government is not that high
functioning
[Music]